[Musique]
mes petits amis ce soir nous allons
faire un jeu très amusant mon chapeau
mon échelle et hop hop hop hop hop hop
hop hop hop hop hop
m cantonnet d'actu lui ramène à gros
sabots oui il ne mettra que y ait du
soleil
bonsoir la compagnie
jeunesse pigeon vole
c'est comme ma femme c'est très facile
c'est moi qui commence comme ça va tu le
dois attention je viens d'un vol oui
elle va
[Musique]
nous nicolas la table ne vole pas tu
dois faire un gars à moi de jouer
avions volent
poule vol file vole elle vole pas pr
neil un gars ça vole cornichons un gars
vous allez payer engage tous les trois
étoiles qui n'a pas caché non moi je
joue bien voilà comme gaz vous allez
faire le tour de la table en sautant sur
actu
[Musique]
et maintenant c'est à moi non non
non non ce deuil nos essais vous même
alors
à gauche mais
non mon chapeau
mon chapeau on sait moins c'est plus
beau chapeau mon coup de chapeau
oh là là je vais bientôt c'est plus
prudent
il est plutôt bruyant ce jeu de pigeon
vole pas trop patron regardez mon
chapeau mon pauvre chapeau on dirait une
galette le tarn au monde nous pauvres ne
nous allons ne te lamente pas donne moi
ton chapeau la merci tu vas voir
2 3 et voilà tiens qui est consolé au
sens lors
merci patron vous savez en faire deux
choses en route bonne nuit des enfants
fait de pauvres
[Musique]